in this video we're going to be taking a
very close look into a property
developer who claims to have made
millions of pounds in his property
development business he goes by the name
developer Creeks but his real name is
Rudy Andrew KN and guys I like to say
I'm not like any other developer I'm not
afraid to get my hands dirty the more
projects the more profit now the first
time I ever came across rud was when he
made a video and he referenced me so
this guy's obviously been watching
Samuel leads somebody asked him the
question they said do you take into
account bridging finance and development
finance charges when you're looking at
your developments and his response was
well I just do everything cash me
personally I will use cash to buy every
single project but this guy young guy
came to have made millions of pounds and
he doesn't even need bridging Finance
wow I was impressed however he recently
did another video specifically about me
where he broke down one of my property
developments namely St ANS in Lincoln
and he basically said that I was lying
he said that my figures didn't stack
there were incorrect figures and that
made me decide to not only defend myself
but to take a little bit of a deep dive
into developer Creeks who jumped on Tik
Tok and believes half the things you see
in it Samuel Leeds has just finished a
property development project but the
prophet he's saying just simply don't
add up I'm going to break it down for
you to show you that these figures just
can't be true according to him he made a
500 20K profit these are the numbers but
I'm going to make it a bit easier to
follow let's first go through the cost
so the plot was
33k that would make the stamp Duty
16.4k let me just step in right there he
says with such Authority you know the
stamp D he would have paid would have
been 16.4 th000 where on Earth are you
getting 16.4 th000 from I don't know cuz
even if I bought an investment property
that was a residential property it would
be more like 13.9 but this is land
you're a millionaire property developer
that builds houses all the time if
you're a developer and you buy land to
build houses then you should know that
when you buy land you get commercial
rates the stamp Duty for the first
quarter of a million p is zero and after
that it ends up being 5% and then
there's a threshold so the land that I
purchased my stamp Duty cost Me 2 and a
half Grand how is this guy a property
developer has he ever bought a piece of
land to build on before still I don't
know the exact area works out to be 27k
again showing your ignorance you really
don't know what you're talking about the
price that I gave of 330 Grand included
stamp Duty and included s tax we then
have the solicitors fees of 14k I don't
know which solicitors you use but if
you're paying
£14,000 you probably need a new
solicitor or have you never actually
paid a solicitor before because maybe
you don't actually own any land we can't
forget the build cost he's not building
any cheaper than £180 per square foot
he's not building for any less than 972
Grand really cuz I've got the receipts
that I paid the builders now this
development was a few years ago this was
done in 2020 however when I posted on
Tik Tok recently with the development I
said looking back at a previous
development so it's not like I'm trying
to pretend that this was a new
development it's very well documented
and then you got the planning cost I've
allowed 20K for this it already had plan
so my planning fees were zero what why
did you make this video and why would I
do a development that was going to lose
me money just doesn't make any sense so
I responded to his video and I said I
documented this site four years ago on
YouTube you lost me at the stamp Duty
being 16.4 th000 where did you get this
calculation he responds using the stamp
Duty calculate it on the government
website okay so we just gone straight to
the website and just used the normal
residential Cal calculator um and I said
the calculator you used was not for
commercial land and it already had
planning permission and I put all the
money in myself with no lending I'm
happy to show you the evidence of the
build at £500,000 if you agreed to them
posting a full apology video and I'm
just a good
negotiator he then deleted my comments
so now I'm like all right what the
heck's going on here so I messaged rudo
and I said to rudo Friendly warning take
it down or I will have no choice between
my solicitors to take immediate action
tomorrow he then blocks me right I'm
thinking is this dude really a
professional so my lawyers messaged him
the following morning and sent him a
full breakdown of the development to
prove that actually everything I said
was true and his video was complete
nonsense um and said look these are all
these are all the receipts these are all
figers we literally sent him all the
bank statements and everything we didn't
have to do this but I was like yeah show
him everything cuz if he knows that he's
is completely wrong then maybe he'll put
an apology video up I got another update
on the developer KS versus Samuel Le
Saga he then does some week video where
he says oh um to be fair to Samuel I can
confirm that his lawyers did send me the
the figures and and I can now confirm
and to be fair to him he has now sent me
the figures of the build and I can
confirm that and then the video cut so
he doesn't want to apologize he doesn't
want to take down the videos even though
he knows that everything he said about
my figures not stacking up was wrong
because he he's seen the receipts so
Rudy Andrew knots my understanding is
that he's about 22 years old he did a
little bit of football he wanted to play
professionally and uh that didn't work
out for him but then luckily from my
research his mom married a rich guy and
his name is Justin not and he runs a
very successful property development
company called balmore homes limited now
balore homes limited has been g a very
long time and makes good money so
respect kudos to Justin not for building
a nice property development company
however how does Rudy developer Creeks
fit into all of this well from what I
can see he doesn't even work for the
company he's not a partner he's
certainly not a shareholder he has zero
assets or ownership of this company
Rudy's got his own development company
his company's called calev homes limited
however doesn't seem to be doing very
well in fact calev Holmes owns no homes
doesn't own any land never bought any
properties C Holmes has got current
assets £2
2,728 but here's the other problem uh
that company also has a creditors yep of
£
2723 which leaves his complete net worth
at a whopping £5 so how does Rudy look
so successful how did even I at first
glance when I was saw Rudy on Tik Tok
property developer kiks think wow this
kid seems to be doing well because what
he does is on a Sunday when the builders
aren't there and when no one's around
what he does is he goes to mommy and
daddy's development sites and he gets
his phone and he shiftily makes little
videos and says hey I invested in this
land and I did this and I did that you
didn't know did you Rudy you didn't put
any money in in fact it's not your
development site it it's your mommy and
daddy's development site when I realize
this I thought surely not surely you
wouldn't have the audacity to go and
stand outside someone else's house
someone else's development and in the
comments people are always begging him
can we go inside can we go inside and
he's like oh yeah we'll go inside soon
we'll go inside soon I'm about to give
you a tour of the
inside but before we do that let me tell
you some specifications of this
house let me go show you the gardens and
give you a quick Glimpse inside this is
the kitchen Diner right and you can see
big massive Gardens like dude have you
not got keys if they were really your
developments you'd be showing the build
process you'd be going inside you'd have
records I bought this land and I'm such
a great developer they don't make
developers like me anymore and guys I I
like to say I'm not like any other
developer guys you're not seeing this
anywhere else who's doing it at my age
to this level so I did a little bit of
digging and I found the addresses and
I'm not going to reveal this publicly on
YouTube because that would be unfair but
every single property that you see
developer Creeks standing outside is not
owned by him it's owned by Mommy and
Daddy so why would Rudy pretend that
they were his maybe Rudy feels a sense
of purpose maybe Rudy is doing it to try
and raise Finance for his own failing
development company maybe Rudy's trying
to be a guru and sell mentorship courses
to get money on on the back of mommy and
daddy's success I have a series you can
buy from the link on this video this is
the cheapest option he is at best an
apprentice for his mom and dad Rudy you
are broke you are not a developer you do
not make millions and millions of pounds
you go around mommy and daddy's
developments film tape videos and that
makes sense that's why you didn't know
how much the stamp Duty would be on a
land you didn't know the figures you
don't know the cost of things cuz you
never done one yourself and even your
videos where he does breakdowns his
videos are very very cut it's almost
like he goes around his mom's house what
were the uh figures mom on that
development that that that Daddy did uh
okay and what did the build cost do and
what was the all right thanks and then
he goes on a Sunday I bought this land
for um it's embarrassing I actually feel
really bad for him I don't think I'm
going to sue him I mean geez even if I
did Sue him uh best Cas is I might make
£5 from it failed footballer failed Road
man fa failed property developer now
he's trying to grow his brand on TiK ToK
by tearing me down for clickbait now
he's failed at that too just stop you're
embarrassing yourself he come someone
said you're just a marketing man never a
builder it shows developer KS comments
here what's your company search up mine
bmore homes limited on company's house
the numbers speak for themselves it's
not your company so what's the lesson
here I guess there's a couple of lessons
Liston number one is be careful when you
see people posting their success on Tik
Tok do your research and make sure that
they actually are if you're watching
this and you want to see the full
costings of the breakdown of my
development in Lincoln and see how much
I spent how much profit I made how much
I bought the land for how much the stamp
Duty was I will leave a link below in
the description where you can download a
PDF and I'll show you the full breakdown
of all the figures on this particular
site the second thing is when you see
people talking nonsense about me on Tik
Tok or anywhere know that it is just for
clout it is just for views it is never
true I can always clap back whether that
be legal whether that be with a video
like this I can always clap back always
got something these guys just totally
doing it for views and he knew that the
the information was wrong he was saying
he just didn't care but number three is
this you're watching my YouTube channel
you're probably going to end up becoming
rich successful I imagine cuz you're one
of my viewers I hope that you do when
you become successful when you become
rich please please please read a
parenting book because I tell you
something Justin not he's a great
developer successful I respect that let
me tell you something I'm a dad I got
three kids if my son started go around
taking videos of my developments taking
credit for my work saying I invested
millions of pounds I did this and I did
that prancing around on Tik Tok I'd be
embarrassed I'd be ashamed I wouldn't
let it happen so if you watch this video
and you watch my videos and you end up
going being rich and successful read a
parenting book and do not let your kids
end up like Rudy developer
creeks
[Music]
a